je sais pas et aujourd'hui on se trouve
sur la mise à jour 2 de forrest
l'alphabet 0.05 start c'est parti cette
fois ya trois trucs nouveaux qui vont
beaucoup nous intéresser je vous montre
ça dans un instant le temps que je
construise ma petite cabane
forcément on va encore se crasher 1
c'est pas possible qu'on vivent
tranquillement dans cet avion a dévoilé
ses parties alors non mais attends je
commence trop bien j'ai mangé 3b
empoisonné je suis en train d'essayer je
suis mort en menant à temps mais je peux
pas commencer bon puis au moins on va
trouver voilà une corde on en a besoin
on a eu l'accord très bien à la bad doit
y avoir du monde veut voir qu'on se
batte tentant mais pourquoi j'ai pas la
promenade entame un mic ben oui pourquoi
tu es dans ta poche
salut les copains ça fait longtemps
alain bas depuis la mise à jour en fait
pour être exact mais c'est pas comme ça
qu'on fait des retrouvailles un mois je
me fâche et voilà c'est comme ça que je
me fâche bassée en mourant je crois que
ça fait depuis la première vidéo qu'on a
fait sur ce fort est que je n'avais pas
été aussi nul à chier
oui les médicaments donnés mois plein de
choses plein show jon valises j'aime
bien tout ça et vous savez quoi
ces mouettes là elles nous servent
désormais bon encore faut-il réussir les
habitants ils sont forts ils sont
fourbes désormais leurs plumes servent à
faire des flèches up plumes
alors est ce qu'on construit notre petit
abri à côté de ce breuvage exotique un
oui parce que je connais un petit peu la
culture indigène
alors désormais une petite animation g à
sderot d'un homme la petite main voilà
c'est tout pour moi très bien on a notre
shelter c'est parfait pour effet de lui
d'un coup mais on n'en fait jamais la
même touche pour avancer que pour que
pour sauvegarder justement du coup la
nuit tombe alors déjà maintenant il fait
plus de 1000 noir quand on a dormi mais
la nuit tombe délicatement hockey le feu
est bon pour faire cuire notre lapin au
nom en ans déjà sans déconner bon vous
me fait plus peur des puits dans la
première vidéo un don vous avez commencé
par brûler s'il vous plaît non s'il vous
plaît souvenons attend déjà tu me laisse
récupérer ma hache si vous me permettez
juste deux secondes je mange mon lapin
et on continue auquel il n ya pas de
problème voilà c'est bon et généreux
dormi ils sont partis du coup alors ils
vont regarder dormir tranquillement
voilà petit carnage alors première
nouveauté les gens on peut faire à
l'aide d'un stick et d'un morceau de
vêtement une torche voilà bon shekels à
voilà une belle torche comme ça c'est
affreux ivoiriens en fait la torchère l
écrire juste mon visage pour que les
animaux voient mieux
mais l'éclair absolument mal le reste il
respire il se tourne vers moi regarder
l'eau regardez-moi ça il se tourne vers
moi il veut monde est quoi ca suffit
[ __ ] donc là j'étais guérie mais c'est
une blague
c mais c'est plat il va me tuer dans le
dos rond chez moi tranquillement sans
déconner on voit trois fois moins quand
j'ai une torche que quand j'ai pas de
torches boom
pas de pitié oui les plus petites plumes
bombe par derrière
voilà en plus attends attends mais qu'il
meure tu vas me poser à côté de lui quoi
bas merci beaucoup
ça me fait très plaisir et je peux pas
ramassées la carcasse pour la faire
cuire ac marco rojas de forêt sont bien
qu'arnaud psychopathe quoi tuer des
oiseaux pour les faire cuire va faire
cuire les indigènes 6 juin crée avec
deux plantes ce truc voilà c'est un truc
qui restaure la vie voilà donc immense
sac une petite soupe avec une cuillère
et un bol 1
ce qui n'a pas de coeur et pas de bol
qui marchait dans ses mains comme un
gros porc en tout cas c'est l'histoire
de la vie voilà ça peut vous être utile
en cas de bataille très viril contre des
indigènes plumes avec un stick
ah bah ça marche ça fait trois quatre
flèches ok on a 28 flèche mais on n'a
toujours pas dark c'est pas trop de
bonnes nouvelles
je propose qu'on mange et qu'on a dans
une grotte regardez regardez ça c'est le
petit déjeuner ces petits jets dans ce
fort est chaque il a rien fait alors
qu'on retrouve une grotte pour choper la
corde là que j'ai eu au début dans la
vidéo et on va pouvoir créer l'arc
regardez hop ça se voyait à sa manière
de voler qu'il attendait un coup de
hache pour nous donner des plumes voilà
je sais qu'ici il ya une grotte ça c'est
nouveau aussi et passe à avoir des
nouvelles h
mais pris en chasse vous pensez il m'a
pris en chasse les rues de richesse
regardez le il est plus là [ __ ] il
fourbit ses parties dans la grotte
j'espère au moins qu'ils aient une corde
non voilà comme ça quatre d'un coup il
en reste un petit on va le finir à la
hache
non mais on fait quoi et que la lampe
plaint mekki qui éclaire le coin en haut
à droite avec une lampe
voilà merci alors une corde rajab plein
plein de cordes au plafond un mais
malheureusement au bout des cordes et
des trucs un peu glauque
c'est quoi ça aux indes ordi mais qu'est
ce que les autres faisaient qu'un pc
bordel skis joué à un haut des mineurs
peut-être yes
maintenant si je me souviens bien il
faut une corde un stick un truc de
vêtements
oh là là on s'entraide avisé déjà ou pas
[ __ ] tu as comme quoi tient une flèche
aux dérives qui tient un petit bout ce
que j'ai cru voir quelque chose on va
pouvoir un peu ce s'exercer comme on dit
au rugby on lui a mis en plein dedans et
à toi au plat entre les deux tétons j'ai
vu bien des saluts l'a dit j'aime que
fais tu dans ce caillou hop là on est
bien on est bien dans cette caverne bon
petit soldat tranquillement cas identité
monsieur tu as même un soda sur ta
chaussures donc je te remercie ça me
fait très plaisir
il ya plein de souda ici
truc de dingue y avait un [ __ ] de
distributeurs automatiques dans l'avion
qui s'est écrasé ici c'est pas possible
quoi regarder pas leur proposer de faire
une fête quoi y assez de soldats pour
tous les indigènes plus - pour aller
dégagement d'ici décède
voilà tombe dans le caillou dans le
néant alors est ce que cette fois je
vais pouvoir faire une bombe qui
marchent en je la sens bien
oui alors je crois que c'est un fumigène
totalement inoffensive voilà un gaz
sucré mais à chaque fois que j'ai voulu
faire péter quelque chose avec une boum
ça n'a pas marché dit le haut témoigne
jean avec ta posture nul meurt on
regarde tout ce qu'on a dans notre
inventaire c'est pas un sac qu'il a
c'est une énorme valise c'est sûr je sûr
qu'un jour cet art il va se passer
quelque chose avait en fait il fait tout
bon ou encore regarder c'est un toboggan
à et voilà qu on retrouve jackson on la
mène ici [ __ ] ou à la manie si on
prend des photos ça faire des petits
souvenirs quand même comme ça en
attention ces moments de chasse terrain
est mauvais à un peu plus bas alors je
les regardais les décédés ouais diplôme
de chasseurs hop y avait une arrivée en
dessous regardez on chasse l'araignée
[ __ ] non elle a un venin très puissant
je cherchais un autre cas du bain il
faut la suivre elle va nous mener au
touché un caillou up et voilà ça marche
et merci à renier quoi ce bordel on
n'est pas dans matrix plat mais au
regard du otis à la flèche tranquille à
elle se pose là va il est dit n'est pas
encore trop tard petite flèche ne me
déçoit pas non plus mais les flèches
pour regarder [ __ ] matrix bon il faut
que je me connais je crois mais même pas
regardé l'admettre hall elle s'en fout
il ignore totalement moeurs assez bien
voilà c'est la première proie comment
fais tu dis moi comment fais tu [ __ ]
attendez attendez l'internât 13e 100 kg
de poussée
j'aime pousser
oh oh oh je m'y attendais tellement pas
mon dieu c'est incroyable ce qui s'est
passé tu sembles bouger encore un peu ou
peut-être me dit ça pour me rassurer
2e 2e instinct 2 à temps mais elle a
volé une flèche
mais cette [ __ ] mois d'avril et une
flèche mais tu voles pas mes flèches ne
me vois pas mes copains voilà alors ça
c'est l'homme des uns comme dans chaque
épisode the forest
on va manger les enfants 1 qu'est ce qui
s'est passé est ce qu'elle voulait faire
cuire un côté molotov mais arrête ça l'a
brûlée au nom au lieu des plumes oh non
je suis désolé je peux faire et de
l'indigène regarder le un seul ben oui
tu m'as vu alice ou plusieurs en fait ça
commence par lui je vous ai un peu
sous-estimé alors tu m'attaques je te
parle ne bouge surtout pas
c'est l'heure de la bombe ça va péter à
toi t'as pas compris d'accord non mais
attends qu'est ce que c'est que c'est
bon je vous dis ça fait de la fumée à
base de fraises tagada quoi il ya une
petite musique de fête foraine quand tu
l'as lens toutes les cordes va pouvoir
faire un business d'arc les mecs me
kidnappe me fous dans une grotte et il
me laisse ton équipe n'y a pas de
problème il un art qu'on s'en fout il a
du feu on s'en fout il a mis très pour
tout te tuer on s'en fout c'est un bébé
indigènes [ __ ] ils poussent dans le
sol comme ça en fait comme des fruits et
légumes
on apprend tous les jours je vais écrire
un livre sur les indigènes de a à z ça
sent le mutant aux le mutant qui tombe
du ciel
on peut là tu es un peu là dessus on
peut la tuer via la famille tente au nom
helen barrières anti feu est-ce que ça
va la tuer la bombe
elle arrête le temps regarder
adéquat oh mon dieu elle fait pas c'est
quoi cette femme cailloux là ça suffit
arrête petite pépite sûrs voilà allez ça
finit dans le rocher tout ça je cherche
la sortie et je trouve des indigènes
avec amusez-vous
non mais vraiment calmé vous parce que
moi j'ai fait du free fight il était
plein d'eau 1 les mêmes du krav maga
ok alors alors alors vous êtes en train
de défoncer ou que je courais je m'en
vais tout nu voilà pourquoi pas demain
contre 1 à est ce que vous trouvez ça
fair play vous à je survis 0 jours on
n'avait pas vu ça depuis le début de la
vidéo
bon les managers c'est déjà la fin de
cette vidéo sera mise à jour 2 de forêt
j'espère que là qu'avait fait je vous
auront plus n'hésitez pas à me dire si
vous qu'ils fassent de forest si vous
êtes un peu lassé auquel cas je ferai
une vidéo formation je n'ai pas une
toutes les deux semaines parce que là il
ya une mise à jour toutes les deux
semaines
donc du coup je ferai une vidéo toutes
les deux mises à jour voilà apprend les
maths avec le cas dans tous les cas
jusqu'à vos vacances se passe super bien
que vous vous reposez que vous dites et
que vous faites ce que vous avez et
celle important surtout retenir deux
nouvelles vidéos
merci d'avoir regardé celle ci je suis
plein de gestes en plus bizarre que mes
bras comme si j'avais plein de spasmes
on sent toute évidence nouvelle vidéo
vous savez quoi faire avec ces deux
doigts mettez les sur votre temple ils
vont retourner pas car vos parents vous
des visages ronds en disant qu'est ce
que fait notre enfant mais on s'en fout
on s'en fout nous sommes libres nous
sommes mais je sais pas pis bon là je me
suis un peu enflammé 1
[Musique]